und waren sie gestern Abend auch so
wahnsinnig gerührt großer Zapfenstreich
für Angela Merkel
und auch nach all den Jahren schafft es
die Frau tatsächlich noch uns Bürger zu
überraschen jedenfalls mit ihrer
Zapfenstreich Songauswahl das hatten wir
da alles für mich soll's rote Rosen
regnen Knef irgendwas mit Gott + der
legendäre DDR Hit du hast den Farbfilm
vergessen von Nina Hagen dann grüßt
quasi eine Punk Oma die andere
verschiedene Medien behaupten heute die
Kanzlerin sei gestern gerührt gewesen
aber das ist ja gerade das sympathische
an Merkel dass ihr Gesicht selbst in
solchen Parkhaus Momenten eigentlich nur
sagt Jungs macht Hilber ich habe
Kartoffelsuppe auf dem Herd wo bei
Berührung definitiv in Ordnung wäre denn
es ist ja schon eine Ära zu Ende
gegangen gestern Abend war eine verdammt
lange Ehre und dann wird ja Mitte
nächster Woche es ist geplant die
Amtsübergabe stattfinden also was bleibt
von dieser Kanzlerschaft 60 Jahre schon
eine muss man ja fast sagen
außergewöhnliche spektakuläre
[Applaus]
richtig gefühlt waren das ziemlich genau
60 Jahre ein menschenjahr sind 4
Kanzlerin Jahre glaube ich übrigens Olaf
Scholz weiß auch schon was bei seinem
Zapfenstreich gespielt werden soll wir
sind die Roboter von Kraftwerk natürlich
das Musikkorps übt schon
ein Smart klingt einfach alles geil
morgen musste ich Herr Scholz den Ampel
Koalitionsvertrag noch von seiner Partei
also von der SPD absegnen lassen und
wenn er dann endlich verrät wer
Gesundheitsminister wird gibt's
möglicherweise heftige Diskussion
und auch bei dem grünen hat's hinter den
Kulissen neulich ordentlich gescheppert
Fundis Realos wie in alten Zeiten Cem
Özdemir Verso Anton Hofreiter es kann
nur einen geben also ein
Landwirtschaftsminister geben Politik
ist halt ein wahnsinnig gnadenloses
Business selbst bei den Ökos Anton
Hofreiter schiebt Frust nur die Möwe auf
dem Pulli wirkt lustig
erstens
zweitens die Möwe ist überhaupt nicht
lustig
ist es denkbar dass ein Anton Hofreiter
schlicht nicht mehr zu den glatt
gebügelten Manufactum Grün von heute
passt kann das sein guck dir die fünf
Minister innen inklusive außen an die
sind so schön da brauchst du nichtmal
Photoshop Cem Özdemir könnte morgen
Werbung für Nespresso machen dagegen
einen Anton Hofreiter an der hat
wenigstens noch Ecken und Kanten und
weil er auch mit seinen Inhalten
gelegentlich aneckt guckt er jetzt in
die Röhre als gelernter Biologe wer der
Mann ein idealer Landwirtschaftsminister
deswegen ist der linke Flügel der Grünen
jetzt natürlich traurig
auch weil die Partei freiwillig auf das
Verkehrsministerium verzichtet seit 1990
hat der Verkehrssektor seine CO2
Emissionen um 0% reduziert genau da wäre
also grüne Politik bitter nötig Robert
Habeck ist trotzdem voll happy mit den
Grünen Ministerien und vergreift sich
einmal mehr im Metaphern Regal was
bildet sich daraus ab ein Kleeblatt ein
vierblättriges Kleeblatt Wirtschaft und
Klima und Umwelt und Landwirtschaft Iris
Horst die sich in der Vergangenheit
permanent blockiert haben auf einmal
können sie zusammenarbeiten und das
Außenministerium ist soll ich sagen die
Blüte der Stängel
da hat wohl einer einen Stängel Pflege
geraucht wie
könnte es sein dass nur eine Theorie
könnte es sein dass die Grünen fürs
Außenministerium auf den Verkehr
verzichtet haben da mit Annalena
baerbock mal ein bisschen populärer wird
falls ja ist der Preis sehr hoch im
Koalitionsvertrag
kommt das Wort Verkehrswende insgesamt 0
mal vor
ich bin nicht direkt vom Fach aber für
eine erklärte Umweltpartei ist das wenig
im Wahlprogramm der Grünen stand noch
z.b. dass Deutschland ein Fahrrad Land
werden soll dafür wollten sie die anzahl
der Radwege verdoppeln so im Ampel
Vertrag heißt es jetzt die vorhandenen
Mittel für Radwege werden wir absichern
das super es werden also zumindest keine
vorhandenen Radwege wieder abgebaut muss
man wohl dankbar sein auch die
Abschaffung der diese Subvention hat es
genauso wenig in den Vertrag geschafft
wie das Tempolimit man könnte sagen
unser neuer Vizekanzler ist ein
ziemlicher Verkehrswende half er wobei
mir gerade einfällt warum sollte ich
noch mal unbedingt den Grünen wählen
und schon allein dafür dieses
Verkehrsministerium zu einem wirklichen
Infrastruktur Ministerium des Jahres
2021 umzubauen lohnt es sich am 26.9
Grün zu wählen
die Grünen wählt man wegen Verkehr und
kriegt dann zur Belohnung einen FDP
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing alias
aus Puff Daddy
erste Amtshandlung noch vor Amtsantritt
er prüft die KFZ Steuer zu senken um
höhere Diesel steuern auszugleichen
tierisch gut an bei den Grünen dafür ist
wissen jetzt ganz offiziell
Schutzheiliger aller Diesel Pilot zu
seinen Ehren gibt es 24 Stunden am Tag
danke Volker Autokorsos sein Geburtstag
wird zum offiziellen Feiertag
Allerheiligen an jeder Tanke bekommt man
die Volker Plakette für den Rückspiegel
und Volker wird der beliebteste
Kindernamen und zwar für Jungs und für
Mädchen
als hoch hatten wir halten fest im
Unterschied zu SPD und Grünen herrscht
bei der FDP auffällig gute Laune
sehr viel Harmonie und gar kein MK soft
warum weil die Liberalen diese
Koalitionsgespräche gewonnen haben
natürlich klarer Sieger man spricht
schon vom süßen Duft des gelben Erfolges
dieser Moment wenn du als kleinste
Partei aus den Ampel Gesprächen kommst
und wie machst du es Ministerposten
abgesamt hast weil die anderen zu blöd
waren alter du hast es derartig drauf
genieß es einfach lieber weil der Duft
der grüne provoziert
Auto Motor Sport TV mit till Reiners
Hallo
Deutschland und das Auto das gehört
zusammen wie SUV und Spielstraße aber
jetzt gibt's nur neue Regierung und da
wollen wir Autoliebhaber natürlich
wissen wie viel PS bringt die auf die
Straße wie sieht die neue
Verkehrspolitik aus wenn man im
Wahlkampf der Grünen verfolgt hat konnte
einem ja ganz Angst und Bange werden die
Ökos wollten eine Verkehrswende weniger
Autos Tempolimit und du sollst mehr
zahlen wenn ein Auto klimaschädlich ist
muss man sich mal reinziehen ich soll
dafür bezahlen dass meine Karre geile
ist das ist der Hubraum night der
Fahrradfahrer zum Glück hat sich die FDP
bei den Ampel Verhandlung zu 100%
durchgesetzt woher kommt eigentlich die
bedingungslose Autoliebe der liberal in
meiner Familie gibt es sogar die Legende
mein erstes Wort sei Auto gewesen und
Malz Grundschüler habe ich Micky Maus
gelesen und Autobild Micky Maus und
Autobild die Fixsterne der deutschen
Verkehrspolitik im Nachhinein total
unnötig dass wir uns Sorgen gemacht
haben kaum in der Regierung stehen die
Grünen Domino Day wer fällt zuerst um
die Pendlerpauschale bleibt genau wie
das Dienstwagenprivileg
denn dem verdanken wir ja das doch so
viele fette Boliden über unsere Straßen
cruisen mehr als zwei Drittel aller
Neuwagen mit über 200 PS sind
Dienstwagen kostet den Staat zwar
zwischen drei und sechs Milliarden Euro
pro Jahr ist aber drauf angelegt beim
Verkehr haben die Grünen wirklich gar
nichts durchgesetzt oder Robert
halt richtig ich habe Schulung ich habe
die Argumentation
ich habe die Argumente
Verkehrsanwalt
dringender als wir Autofahrer ständig
als Sündenböcke herhalten für über
Fahrradfahrer über die kaputte
Stoßstange GT 1 ich sage weg mit dem
Einfluss der super mächtigen
Lastenfahrräder soll mit einer Milliarde
Euro subventioniert werden
ist bemerkenswert die die Chinesen haben
jetzt Jahrzehnte daran gearbeitet die
Rikscha und das Fahrrad aus der
Innenstadt los zu werden bei uns heißt
es sie brauchen neue Fahrräder
ein Irrsinn wir brauchen nicht mehr
Fahrradwege sondern weniger Fahrradwege
sind Feiglinge jede Straße ist immer
auch ein Fahrradweg nur halt einer der
auf Regen bleibt wartet Ampel
Verkehrspolitik läuft jede Beweis kein
geringerer als Andi scheuer sagt Zitat
schön dass die Ampel meine Arbeit der
letzten Jahre fortsetzt der ultimative
Ritterschlag wenn Andi scheuer dir sagt
besser könnte ich es auch nicht guten
Abend
[Musik]